[Música]
mario por eso no voy al espacio para
después no sentirme más de mal mal de la
salud por eso vamos a hablar de nuestra
salud aquí en esta sección de directo
américa con usted más romero sala ya
está conmigo en el estudio mar ahora sí
la saludo muy buen día feliz martes para
ti empezamos en afganistán porque
finalmente los talibanes permitieron las
campañas de vacunación contra la polio
en ese país si nos quedamos en la tierra
raúl donde se está más aseguró pero no
siempre en afganistán sin embargo
tenemos una buena noticia y es que
nosotros dudábamos la comunidad
internacional también dudaba de que
efectivamente empezaran las vacunas
contra la polio en el país porque los
talibanes hasta el momento habían
prohibido este tipo de campañas en las
zonas donde donde tenían control en los
últimos tres años algo que de hecho
había llevado a un aumento de los casos
de polio especialmente entre los niños
que recordemos que es una enfermedad que
afecta a esta esta población sobre todo
a los menores de 5 años repasemos las
cifras de unicef en 2020 se detectaron
350 casos de polio en todo el país un
aumento drástico respecto al año
anterior sin embargo en 2021 por ahora
sólo llevamos 1 de polio detectado en
afganistán no se sabe si es un problema
de detección por la convulsa situación
que ha vivido el país o si efectivamente
es así sólo ha habido una transmisión de
este virus en caso de que sea así es una
oportunidad de oro para intentar caminar
hacia la erradicación de la
poliomielitis que afecta a tantas
personas en ese en ese país y por eso el
objetivo de la vacunación también es
inmunizar a unas 10 millones unos 10
millones de niños a lo largo de cuatro
campañas de varias campañas en estos en
este año sin embargo las dificultades
para cumplir con estos objetivos son
varios y nuevos sólo son los talibanes
escuchemos algunos de los trabajadores
de las campañas de ahí y aquí hacemos de
aquí en ciclo podemos erradicar la polio
de nuestro país por varias razones hay
algunas restricciones de las familias
hay problemas de seguridad y no estamos
bien equipados
explotadores una memoria como visitarán
habitable brabo en mozart más numerosa
no hemos recibido la medicación contra
la polio a tiempo y muchas familias
rechazan vacunar a sus hijos porque hay
rumores de que la vacuna de la polio
puede hacerles daño
recordemos afganistán y pakistán son los
dos únicos países del mundo donde la
polio sigue siendo endémica y además es
una enfermedad que no tiene tratamiento
la vacuna es la única opción y de hecho
la mejor opción para combatirla
recordemos también además que este tipo
de enfermedad provocada por un virus
muchas veces transmite transmite sin
muchos síntomas pero en 1 de cada 200
casos llega a provocar parálisis en los
niños y puede también tener efecto a
largo plazo en los adultos sí pues marc
ahora dejamos afganistán para hablar de
los nuevos datos sobre el tratamiento de
la farmaceútica regeneron contra el coi
19 volvemos a nuestra página que estamos
viviendo le pregunto cuáles son estas
novedades más no nos va a dejar en un
buen tiempo esta es una buena noticia
también el titular un poco sería que que
parece que esta protección que ofrece
este tratamiento puede durar al más
largo plazo de lo que creíamos es
recordemos un tratamiento de anticuerpos
monoclonales de esos son los anticuerpos
producidos en el laboratorio que ayudan
a reforzar la respuesta inmune una vez
una persona se ha contagiado de kobe de
19 la importancia de estos datos reside
precisamente en eso ahora solo se sabía
que protegía a corto plazo ante el
riesgo o antes ya el contagio de kobe 19
pero ahora sabemos que esa protección
contra kobe grave tanto
hospitalizaciones como muertes se
mantiene alrededor del 81 por ciento
hasta ocho meses después de haber sido
administrado este tratamiento
actualmente este este tratamiento que se
llama régimen cop de la farmacéutica
regeneron como decías raúl está aprobado
en eeuu para prevenir el commit 19 en
casos de exposición a un contagio de
exposición a una persona que ya está
infectada en personas con riesgo de
generar cobit grave un cuadro grave de
la enfermedad en europa también sólo
para personas que ya han sido
contagiadas sin embargo ahora la
farmacéutica lo que intenta es convencer
de que con estos datos se podría usar de
manera preventiva en la población más
general escuchamos los
estos datos se añaden a la evidencia
creciente que respalda el uso de región
cop para prevenir el commit 19 en
personas no contagiadas algo que podría
ser especialmente útil para las personas
inmunocomprometidas que no responden
adecuadamente a las vacunas y siguen
prisioneros de la pandemia como siempre
igualmente raúl lo mejor es tener una
cierta prudencia estos datos sólo son de
la farmacéutica no han sido revisado por
los entes reguladores entonces mejora
antes de cantar victoria escuchar que
nos dirán estos entes y recordemos
también que este tratamiento fue uno de
los que hicieron al ex presidente
estadounidense donald trump marc pero
ahora dejamos entonces eeuu y él
regeneron y vamos a ir a india donde hay
nuevo brote de psique en ese país motivo
de alarma los mosquitos tampoco la dejan
en paz no de hecho es un motivo de
alarma relativo todavía no está
descontrolado este brote hay 89
contagios entre los cuales hay 17 niños
y una mujer embarazada es el primer
brote que hay en esta región
uttar pradesh sin embargo no es el
primero que ya ha surgido en índia el
primer contagio en esta región por
cierto fue el 23 de octubre para tener
una cierta temporalidad
desde cuanto se ha desarrollado este
este brote india detectó su primer caso
de cica en 2017 y desde entonces se han
detectado varios brotes pequeños
controlados de unas decenas de contagios
en múltiples regiones del país uno de
los motivos de alarma de hecho es que el
virus el virus del vector perdón que
transmite esta enfermedad los mosquitos
como muy bien decías del dragón están
presentes en varias regiones es un
mosquito muy concreto que transmite esta
enfermedad y tiene presencia en muchos
lugares de india eso es uno de los
motivos de alarma que hace que este tema
que se pueda extender en el resto de
lugares del país y la otra cosa es que
él sí que requiere una vigilancia
epidemiológica
sólida pues continuada que en motivos en
tiempos de pandemia es más difícil que
se de norkom y 19 dificulta todo de
estas todos estos controles muchos de
los casos de sica son asintomáticos y se
pasan relativamente rápido pero
recordemos que si se contagia una mujer
embarazada puede llegar a transmitirle
ese virus al bebé que lleva en el
vientre y en ese caso puede provocar
micro en cefaleas o lo vimos no sé si lo
recuerdas y brasil de los brotes más
virulentos que hemos visto pues mar
gracias por toda esta información nos
fuimos mañana miércoles con más